i'm going to go through a couple of
things that i think where where person
is where a present could be in the
future
and hope you find this interesting the
talk is
it's actually it was written for 45
minutes so i have to compress a bit i
won't you know go through all the
details on the slides i will post the
slides after the talk
so a bit about myself i'm mark andre
lemberg i've been using python since
1994 so you know quite a long time it
also tells a bit about my age
i started mathematics i have a
consulting company we're doing python
projects and i'm working as a consulting
cto and senior software architect
i'm also the european society chair at
the moment
i've i'm the founding father of the psf
python core developer
and i am based in dusseldorf
so what's on the agenda for this talk
first i'm going to go through the python
development then i'm going to have a
look at the growth in the market
perspectives for the future i'll give
you a few
ideas about my wish list for python and
then perhaps we have some time for
discussion
uh it's more probably that we're going
to have those in the breakout room
afterwards
so let's head on
into the
overview of the python development so
setting the stage python has been around
around for a long long time
is it still evolving
so let's have a look at the history of
python uh it all started in december
1989 when guido van rassem started to
write python he was working on the abc
team at at that time and he thought well
i would like to do things a bit
differently so he started writing python
in the 1990s
basically everything was done on on
usenet so he posted things there
there was a lot of development it was a
very very small community at that time
and over over the uh the that decade
uh basically python grew 2020 and then
in 2000
um the the zero years what happened is
that the development opened so we had
more
developers come in we had people who got
access to the repository the python
software foundation was initiated
to own the licensing and to own the the
ip rights
and then in the tens
what happened is we moved to different
repository system so first we had to we
start with cfs then we had subversion
then we went to mercurial and then
we went to git eventually and we started
the python 2-3 transition
which is
over by now
luckily so
more recent developments i'm just
highlighting a few things here which are
very important so i think the most
important development are type
annotations
so what we have now in python is
uh you have the possibility to say okay
this this variable is going to be an
integer this variable is going to be a
string or you can even you know there's
a
a way to also define more complex types
in python you can use those type
annotations in several different tools
you can you can have type checks in your
ides for example you can use them in
data classes to
define the variables and then data
classes make it possible by using the
type information to more efficiently
store the information
the other big development is async io so
async io is about the
basically putting an event loop into
python and then managing that event loop
in python to have
parts of your code run as co-routines
meaning that they they run for a certain
time then they give up
um the
the the the task they say okay i'm gonna
have to wait on something they give the
the control back to the event loop the
event loop then takes the next co
routine runs that until that again says
okay
i have to wait so please go to the next
one and that makes it more efficient to
run python code
where you have lots of waiting going on
let's say for example websocket code
um other developments are context-bars
which are threat local variables but for
async code so that's like it goes along
with the async io a very important
development was to have the built-in
dict
be an ordered dict so it preserves the
insertion order
that made a lot of things that we had to
do using meta classes for example in in
orm classes classes
made those go away so basically they got
a lot simpler they could remove the meta
classes and now we just have we have
access to the order
in which
attributes for example were
added to a class sticked directly in
there and data classes already mentioned
it's an efficient way to store
records
we also have a number of new operators
i'm just picking out a few so we have a
new dict merge operator we have the well
worth
operator because it looks a bit like a
walrus it's basically assignment inside
expressions
which makes a couple of things a bit
easier there were long discussions about
this
i won't go into detail but you can read
it up on the mailing list if you like
a very nice development with f strings
so you can format things directly in
uh well you can do sort of like
templating inside python
with the direct access to locals these
are not only you know nice to write
they're also efficient because they
execute faster and this was a vastly
successful thing
we have positional keyword only
parameters
these were basically backported from the
c api which had them for a longer time
already and now they're available in
python as well there's a new parser
called peg
this allows us to add new keywords to
the language without you know disrupting
the complete code base because they are
context local
and then in 310 we're now getting the
switch and match statement this is for
structural pattern matching
you can also match on type and and
objects
this is something that's new
and it's uh still has to be seen how how
well that's going to be picked up
we also had some organizational changes
in python so we have a new release cycle
we have year releases now we have a
steering council that took over after
guido stepped down as the bdfl and
retired
um then after a while
uh guido got you know
tired of being retired so
basically he started working again and
he's now working
at a team at microsoft and with the idea
to improve the performance of sees
python which was very nice
and very recently we also have the first
psf developer in residence so the psf
now actually has a higher developer
helping us
to reduce the number of open prs
what's currently on the discussion like
i said
uh there is a
strong discussion about improving c
python performance
is this is not new this has been ongoing
for years and years but now we have a
dedicated team to work on this and they
are working on a specialized
adaptive interpreter and also adding
many small improvements so you will see
some improvements in terms of
performance over the next few releases
and years
we will have enhanced error reporting so
instead of just reporting on which line
something went wrong python will also be
able to report on which column or in
which columns something went wrong
which is going to improve the
the error reporting especially for for
newbies and also in some cases of course
for experts because it's not always
obvious where occurred if you have
longer lines
there's a development to add supper
interpreters to python
the idea there is that to work around
the the guild limitations the global
interpreter lock limitations in python
which makes it hard to run multiple
threads
with python
the the idea with sub-interpreters is
that you can have
you know one sub-interpreter per thread
and then have those run
on on a per thread basis
we are also working on the the c api
so the c api is being basically
[Music]
let's say it's being resorted so uh more
more of the apis that we have are moved
to internal so they're not not going to
be published anymore
to extensions the complexity is supposed
to be reduced a couple of projects on
the way
to to help with all of this to also
maybe change the garbage collector
and to
introduce something called the python
handle instead of using pointers so lots
of work is being done to to improve
python so i think
in terms of the original question
is there still development going on is
is evolution still happening in python
so definitely the answer is yes so
there's lots and lots of stuff coming
so it looks quite good on the on the
python development side
so now let's have a look at the python
growth in the market
if you look at the the history
everything started in 1989 and then very
slowly things got released to the news
groups
the
academic world started picking up python
a lot we had the first workshops here
we had the first company eshop use
python for e-commerce
we even had a browser implemented in
python which was something it was a pet
project of guido at the time
and you can see down here numeric was
started so people in in science were
trying to use python for their
for their uh
tasks
what happened in the next couple of
years is that
python started very much embracing the
web so the first development was the the
zope environment to publish to the web
that was very much object oriented
soap was considered to be a bit too
complex for especially for users so what
happened is that plone
was on the rise plone is a cms system
and you can use it for
basically also for contact content
management and knowledge management in
the enterprise
in the end zop clone was built on on zoe
and so the complexity in the underlying
code was still there so if you wanted to
extend things you still had to go into
soap and do stuff that was considered
you know not to be a good thing for
especially for new developers so
django entered the stage and django made
things uh easier
down here on the uh on the uh access you
see the what happened in the community
so there was a python consortium built
and created to to support python the psf
was founded in 2001. europassen started
pycon started in the us
and things were going well in in terms
of community building
after a while
python started entering the mainstream
so more and more people were using
python you
had
when when you went to customers and you
told them about python people actually
knew what python was which was
exciting too you know if we went to as a
consultant to a company and told them
that we you were using python then they
said oh yes great i know that language
you didn't have to tell them okay
this is a new thing
it's going to be a bit risky for you
but we can still try it i'm going to
tell you it's definitely going to be
worth it
that was the discussion that we had in
the early 2000s
so you can see down here that in the
science area lots of development started
to happen and and this is actually the
next big thing that came after django
so you have a huge list of libraries and
projects pop up in the data science
space and this is where we are right now
so
if you look at the development of of
python and and how
python is being used in the in the
industry it's nowadays it's mostly being
used in data science
of course we still have a use in web
that's not going away anytime soon but
data science is the big driver that we
have at the moment
now question is what's going to happen
in the future and this is basically what
i'm going to try to um
you know make a few suggestions for in
this talk so let's see where we are so
like i said python is still big in web
but web works differently now than it
worked uh you know a decade or two ago
web is definitely not no longer
just about you know publishing content
to the
to the uh websites it's it's nowadays
it's mostly about you know providing an
api a rest api ideally
to
provide data to the front end and then
the front end is typically developed in
javascript using one of the many
frameworks that you have in javascript
we also see async io being used a lot in
in the web to make things run faster
and uh so all this is is going the right
direction python is indeed very well
positioned
in the web not only because of django
but also because of or you know like
clone like the cms
or django cms but it's also well
positioned in terms of api back ends so
we now have fast api
which works based on the async io
framework
we have django and flask rest frameworks
which work synchronously but now they
also are getting a async support
we have libraries that help you with
graphql so you have graphene ariadne
strawberry tati flat
and several others that that help you
you know push data to the front end
so i think
the
the story for for the web is is pretty
good
it is already very big in data science
so python and r are basically the two
main languages that you can use in data
science
um and and this has really dramatically
increased the the uh the scope and the
market share of python overall
and
what what i'm seeing now in the market
is that like we had in the keynote the
heat framework
nowadays everything is about distributed
computing
so we are moving away from having just
one application sit there maybe use
multiple threads to run something
and we're replacing that idea with
moving to multiple processes or even
multi multiple you know machines
clusters working together to to solve a
problem and that's where everything is
moving
and so the the python guild discussion
that we had in the last couple of
decades is actually less important at
this point because
you don't you the gill only runs in in
one of the processes if you have
multiple
processes running already and you have
clusters running multiple machines then
the guild is not so much
of a blocker anymore
so we have two markets covered so what's
what's the idea in the in the enterprise
world
what's happening in in the enterprise
and this is what i'm seeing as you know
cto of companies
i'm seeing that python is entering the
enterprise via data
science so it's no longer the case that
python is just being used for
implementing websites it's also that
python is actually powering
very important parts of enterprises
nowadays because everything is moving
towards being data driven data driven
means that you take the data that you
have you try to analyze it as fast as
possible
and then you try to
build your your decisions the business
decisions on the results that you get
from and
analyzing the data that you have
and and python has uh
has a very strong footing in in that
area so you have for example apache
airflow which is being used for workflow
you have superset being used for
business intelligence so you know
dashboards graphics and stuff
um to put directly on the web and to to
run fast and analytics you have apache
spark which is a data platform which is
distributed and it runs pi spark scripts
so
we are actually well positioned in that
market as well and this is going to grow
so question is is python really ready
for the enterprise
well my take on this is not quite there
yet you know we still have to do some
work on that
and this has to do with a couple of
things now
putting on the cto ad here
where you basically you have to uh
you're responsible for developments that
you're doing in the company and so you
whatever you whatever decisions you make
you have to tell your shareholders you
have to tell your ceo
this is the right thing to do right so
there are a couple of things that that
are a bit worrying
uh when you look at
the python development from the cto side
so one is
the yearly release cycle for example
you get one and a half sub one one and a
half year support for every release now
with the new cycle
you do get faster access to new features
but what's going to happen in companies
is that they will probably not switch to
new releases for every single release
they will skip releases
and so because you only get one and a
half year support for each release
what will happen and what we will have
to see and we will have to have
companies in the python ecosystem
providing this we will need commercial
support for python
so that after those one and a half years
you get support from the core
development team you can then switch to
commercial support that you get from
companies
so it's not it's not um maybe i put it a
bit wrongly so it's not it's not that
bad a thing to happen but you need to
find a different strategy to basically
back up your decision to use python for
this
now how is the core development helping
in this
core developments are good
uh we've added type safety for example
type annotations this is something
that's you know very much liked in the
enterprise
uh people have always had an issue with
you know not having type safety in
python so this is this got added now and
you can write code
using type annotations and in fact in
the enterprise
this will become more and more of a
standard so you will see type
annotations all over the place
so the developments happening in core
develop are actually
a good thing and adding new features is
a good thing in python
it's not so good for for newbies because
python has grown very fast over the over
the years so for example i just looked
at a book
in the last couple of weeks
to just cover the you know basically try
to cover everything that's in python
then it has over 700 pages
so that's where we are at the moment uh
when i looked at the tutorial when i
started to load python i don't remember
exactly how many pages it had but it was
definitely a lot less so
probably like 50 or 100 pages
but this is just core development and so
core development
is not the only contributor to what
python is we also have a huge data
science community we have a huge web
community we have a devops community
so for example ansible or saltstack are
implemented in
in python we have several other
communities in in niche markets so
python is is growing all over the place
and and we have many many people working
on python success so it's not only the
co-development team that
you know provides new features it's also
all these other communities
and what's happening is that lots and
lots of industry leaders are using
python nowadays and so you can reference
those
[Music]
we have companies like airbnb netflix
google microsoft
all of these have have written
applications and they have open source
their solutions and and given them back
to the community so that's great so
could python be seen as the cloud
language
well
i would say yes
but only to some extent there's lots of
competition out there
so especially node.js is one of the big
competitors in that market
we do have lots of apis to all kinds of
cloud libraries to
to cloud solutions you can write
serverless code in python
like awa and bs lambda or google cloud
functions other functions you can write
all those in python it runs in the
browser openstack for example is a
complete cloud solution which is written
in python
so we're in good shape and we have
market awareness
so
could python actually be the new
enterprise language
well of course there's strong
competition from java
and c plus plus and c sharp to some
extent depending on where you go
um the the problem there is you have to
say you know nobody ever got fired for
choosing ibm or nowadays it's more like
nobody ever get fired for choosing java
and so that's what's happening if you
see the enterprise
software development market then still
most of the things are developed in
being developed in java and you can also
see that if you go to
for example the
apache project directory
most of these big applications that they
have are actually written in java so
only very few are written in python
now how can we enter this market
it's difficult
i could tell you people you know love
type languages they they love the
security that they get from type
languages so now we have type
annotations so things are getting better
but i think that we still have to use
this
trojan horse kind of
card
to to get into the enterprise
there's lots of potential that we have
uh these are just you know few acronyms
that you may or may not know i put the
the wording behind these
so but if you look at the the blue
entries in here we only have very few
areas where we actually uh already have
a solution written in python there are
lots of areas in here
where we don't have anything and and
this is a huge market it's billions of
dollars in market size
i have a separate talk on that you can
look and look look look it up it's i
held that in 2018.
so
i think we will get there it just takes
a bit of time and effort
and of course people to you know use
these ideas and then go ahead with them
so this is my wish list for python i
have two slides on this one at the
language level and one at the
application level
so the first one again you know from the
cto kind of perspective what i would
very much like is a python lts version
so something where we can say okay we
will have this
version out it's going to be supported
for five years and then perhaps you can
even get another five-year security fix
it
that would be a great thing that would
be a big selling point in the enterprise
for python
the other things are you know not really
that
that major so of course everyone wants
to have a faster python we would like to
have mobile app support but that's
coming people are working on that
it would be excellent to have a syntax
for parallel execution now that we have
async io already for the asynchronous
execution we're still missing a bit on
the parallel execution there are some
tools
which help you with this and try to
automatically run things in parallel but
it would be nice to have a syntax for
this directly in python we don't have
that yet we still have to rely on
multi-processing mpi das these things
it would be nice to have something
directly in python and of course python
without a guild would be fantastic
this is going to take another
few years to to achieve and because we
don't want another two to three
transition it's going to be hard because
python without a gill is actually going
to break a lot of extensions so we have
to have a good path
towards that now on the application side
of things
i think what we need is
we need better rapid development
solutions
we have good ides for python but those
are not really rapid development
solutions so you still have to do a lot
of boilerplate development
regardless of which area you choose
and the tooling that we have there is
not it's not all that ideal so we we
need more polished libraries we need
business graphics we need business uis
dashboards we need these things to be
backed by companies and not uh not only
open source or well only is not the
right word but you know not
just backed by open source
communities those open source
communities should have
companies
within them
to provide for things like support
backup you know maybe
extended solutions we need more paid
offerings we need more startups that
enter the market and provide easy access
to consultants for example
to provide slas which is something the
enterprise always needs
we need something that makes it
easier to develop applications in python
anaconda is already going in the right
direction for the for the data science
part and they have
very well integrated tools they have a
nice ide they have
deployment tools they have an app store
that's fantastic
but it's too much focus on data science
so we need that in other areas as well
especially if we want to add enter all
these different acronyms that i showed
on the previous slide so
where are we right now
python has a bright future ahead
and things are only going to get better
and it's going to be exciting and it's
going to be fantastic and
this is the end of my talk